hello everybody we just hit 15,000
subscribers holy crap I was actually
watching it it was like fourteen nine
twenty seven and then all sudden it just
exploded and it's now fifteen thousand
three hundred something I don't I don't
know why I think that might have been a
delay with YouTube or something finally
catching up I have no idea but anyway
thank you guys so much it's amazing
because we hit 10,000 subscribers on
September 11th we've gained I don't even
know what day of the week it is we've
gained 5,000 subscribers in - we in 16
days in 16 days we have gained 5,000
subscribers that's incredible and to
think that in my 10,000 subscriber
special which you can see right here I'm
gonna link it right here for everyone
who's new to my channel this video
explains a lot of what I'm about and
what I'm what I'm doing here on YouTube
so it'll explain it better than I could
ever say again but thank you guys so
much thinking that there's five thousand
more people that watch my videos five
thousand more people that subscribed
it's an incredible feeling it's
outstanding I can't even believe that
the growth has just been exponential and
lately I remember month-to-month I was
way I was expecting you know oh I know
next month I'll get them thousand more
subscribers I'm growing so quickly and
I'm just judging by my analytics page
I've gained eight thousand six hundred
and twenty seven in a month over the
past month
it's been incredible and I have nothing
no one else to thank but you guys
because you guys enjoy my videos enough
to share you guys enjoy my video enough
to tell your friends about it and that's
the best feeling that I can get I walked
into this wanting to be an entertainer
and that's all I wanted to do I just
wanted to make people laugh or have fun
or enjoy the videos in the fact that so
many people are are doing that is an
incredible feeling for me is fulfilling
in so many ways to know that people
actually enjoy what I'm doing and it
motivates me to work harder and want to
do better so I don't have any special
video right now but what we got going on
is tonight tonight after
the new Slenderman shadow map gets
released I'm gonna do a playthrough that
that's gonna be up and then I'm going to
do a special livestream tonight where I
this is a special request by someone
else I'm gonna be playing SCP oh wait 7b
again on livestream Haley and I and as a
special request I'm not going to stop
until I beat the game I'm not gonna stop
until I beat the game so I'm hoping
you're gonna be there tonight on my
twitch channel it's also in the
description below just hopefully you
guys can help me through that and also
tomorrow we have we've been working on
what I've been trying to get the kinks
worked out because we discord more drunk
minecraft and we got a special surprise
in that episode that a lot of you have
been asking for I'm not gonna spoil what
the surprise is but you'll you'll all
find out so thank you guys so much 5,000
more subscribers in 16 days is is beyond
every expectation I could have had so
let's keep the momentum going I'm gonna
keep producing the best videos I can if
you if you if all of you out there the
ladies and gentlemen if you all of you
out there are gonna keep sharing I'm
gonna keep making and I'm gonna keep
doing this as much as possible so thank
you guys so much for just watching
that's all I could ever ask of you just
enjoy my videos so thank you for doing
that and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye